hello my name is Billy gin I'm a PhD
student at Cornell University and I have
to present my Droid work with Monica
hensinger Richard peng and my advisor
David Williamson and it's about a
combinatorial cut toggling algorithm for
solving the flashing linear systems
the problem we're interested in solving
is the following given a weighted graph
G and a vector of real numbers on the
vertices of the graph
go also solve the equation LX equals B
where L is a laplacian matrix of the
Gene and is defined as follows
so the partial Matrix the sum of these
rank one matrices
or there's a rank one Matrix for every
Edge
um each Matrix is weighted by the width
of the edge and the rank 1 Matrix itself
is of this form where it has a 1 in the
i i entry a one in the JJ entry and
minus ones in the IJ and j i entrance
so for example for this triangle graph
here where the blue numbers indicates
the weight on the edges
here's the corresponding laplacian
Matrix
why do we care about solving the plush
and linear systems
well it turns out that it's used as an
algorithmic primitive in many
applications from Maxwell algorithms to
analysis of social networks and Beyond
um many people have studied solving LX
equals B in the past for example
Spielman and Tang in 2004 show how to
solve these systems in oh till the M
time
which is much faster than solving a
typical linear system
and the asymptotically fastest algorithm
runs in O of M times square root of log
n time up to poly log factors
and the paper that's most related to our
work is one by Kellner arachia sit for
Andrew from 2013 could give a simple
combinatorial algorithm for solving the
plasma near systems and our paper is
motivated by their algorithm so we'll
Begin by describing their algorithm and
then we'll discard our algorithm
before we move on just a small note so
that all these algorithms and also our
algorithm are not going to solve these
systems exactly rather given a value of
Epsilon the algorithms will find an
approximate solution X that satisfy this
inequality where X star is the optimal
solution to the linear system
um but for complete for clarity we'll
omit the running time dependence on
Epsilon this talk
um it'll turn out that the dependents
will be a multiplicative factor of log 1
over Epsilon
all right so um let's look at the
algorithm of calendar it out which we'll
call the COS algorithm from now on
so
consider this Primal dual pair of convex
optimization problems
let's look at the Dual first the tool is
an unconstrained optimization problem
um and it turns out that the optimal
solution to the jewel is exactly the
same as solving LX equals B this can be
seen by taking the gradient of the
objective and setting it equal to zero
now the Dual of this problem is this
Primal problem here
where the variables are f
the constraints of this problem enforce
that f is a valid B flow of the graph
so what does that mean well a is the
adjacency Matrix of the graph G and so
AF equals b means that the flow flowing
out of every vertex of the graph is
equal to the value of B at that vertex
that's what a b flow is called
and the objective of the Primal is to
minimize the
um L2 normally FF weighted by these
resistances r i j where rij is simply
the reciprocal of the weight on edge i j
um and from now on we'll be working with
the resistance of the graph instead of
the weights just to make the notation
more more simple
and what the coast algorithm does is it
it finds an electrical flow f
and it turns out that once you have an
electrical flow of f you can easily
convert it to
um a solution of LX equals B the convex
programming duality
so
um in particular here's how The Duality
works so if you write out the kkt
optimality conditions for this Primal
dual pair of optimization problems
they're as follows
so f is going to be optimal for the
Primal and X Optimum for the Dual if and
only of the following two conditions
hold
first we need that f is a feasible B
flow
and second to the complementary
selectance condition we need that for
every Edge i j the value of f on the
edge is equal to x i minus x j divided
by the resistance on edge i j for every
Edge in the graph
that's also known as Ohm's law
the COS algorithm is going to use
another law which is called curcos
potential law which is equivalent to
Ohm's law so kpl is going to say that
for all directed Cycles C if you sum
over all the edges in the cycle of the
resistance times the flow that should be
equal to zero
so here's how the code's algorithm works
it's going to begin by Computing a low
stretch spanning GT
um the definition of a low stretch
spanning tree is not going to be
important for really understanding the
algorithm so we're going to admit it in
this talk
um but it's some kind of special
spanning tree in the graph
and it's going to initialize a flow to
be the unique B flow supported on T
since T is expanding tree there's going
to be a unique B flow that's supported
on it and it's going to iteratively
update the flow
um
uh iteration of iteration and it's going
to show that this is going to converge
the optimal electrical flow
in particular here's how each iteration
works
you're going to sample an off tree Edge
um of the graph According to some
probability distribution
and it's going to check if kpl is
satisfied on the fundamental cycle
closed by this off tree Edge
and if it's not satisfied the algorithm
is going to push a constant amount of
flow across the cycle where that
constant is exactly what's needed to
make kpl be satisfied on that skill
the overall running time of these
algorithms as follows
Computing T is going to take old total M
time
and the number of iterations of this
algorithm is going to be also o total of
n this turns out to be equal to the
stretch of this low sets mining tree
and furthermore each iteration which
involves pushing flow along a
fundamental cycle can be implemented
over log n time for duration using a
tree separator data structure or link
cut trees and so the overall running
time of the COS algorithm is nearly
linear in the number of edges in the
graph
so here's a more detailed example of how
the algorithm Works suppose we're
working with this graph here where the
blue edges are the spanning tree
and
um the uh the the block numbers indicate
the values of B
um for Simplicity let's assume that the
resistances are one
at the beginning we initialize F to be
the B flow supported on the blue tree
edges
at iteration we sample a fundamental
cycle in the tree
so for example let's say we sample this
cycle here
note that kpl is not satisfied in this
cycle because the sum of the resistances
times the flow is equal to 2 and not
zero
and so the algorithm is going to
subtract two-thirds from each Edge on
this cycle because that's the number
required so that the resulting flow
satisfies kpl on this cycle
in the next iteration the algorithm
samples another fundamental cycle
um kpl is not satisfied because the sum
is equal to minus five
and so the algorithm pushes the constant
amount of flow along the cycle to
satisfy kpl
note that the flow values are plus are
pushed our plus five thirds plus Five
Thirds and minus five thirds here
because this edge here is directed in
the opposite direction compared to the
other two edges and so pushing flow
along this cycle means that this Edge
will have an opposite sign to the other
two
and the resulting flow will satisfy kpl
and the coast algorithm is keeps doing
this and you can show that this will
make the resulting flow converge to the
electrical flow in a nearly linear
number of iterations
now um cos is less what we call a cycle
toggling algorithm because it really
updates along Cycles
now in network flow Theory another
typical algorithm approach is called cut
toggling and what this involves is that
you're going to maintain potentials X on
the vertices of the graph and in each
iteration the algorithms will sample
some cut s and update the potential on
vertex on all the vertices on one side
of the cut by adding a constant to them
and often s is taken to be a fundamental
cut us on the spanning sheet so
um traditionally for example for Min
cost flow there's many different cycle
toggling algorithms and drool to those
are corresponding cut toggling
algorithms
now dual codes is a cycle of toggling
algorithm but there has no been there's
no dual cut talking algorithm
um for solving laplacian linear systems
known literature
and that motivates us to ask the
following research question which is is
there a cut talking algorithm for
solving the plush and linear systems and
if so how efficiently can it be
implemented
so our main contribution is that yes
there is a dual cut talking algorithm to
the cycle toggling cos algorithm
in terms of how many iterations it takes
we show that it can run in still a
nearly linear number of iterations just
like cos however each iteration has to
take full of end time
moreover
it's unlikely that each iteration can be
implemented in faster than o of end time
via reduction to online Matrix Vector
multiplication which is an algorithmic
problem that's been conjectured to be
hard
therefore straightforward implementation
of dual codes will require old total of
MN timing
however we showed that we can circumvent
this online Matrix Vector multiplication
lower bound because that lower bound
assumes that we Implement each iteration
one at a time
um however in this problem we can
actually generate all the required
updates in advance
and so we can show that if we batch
those updates and process
um many of them at the same time you can
improve get an improved old tilt of
Amazon 1.5 running time and with some
more ideas
um like specification and recursion we
can get it down to Old total of M to the
one plus Epsilon time for any Epsilon
bigger than zero
but for the remainder of this talk I'll
mostly focus on describing the Dual
codes algorithm and maybe sketching how
the batching works
foreign
so recall the kkt conditions for
electrical flow
and so what the coast algorithm did was
it always maintained a feasible fee flow
and it gradually toggled along
fundamental Cycles to gradually satisfy
um the second condition Ohm's law or kpl
on the other hand
what dual codes will do is it's going to
maintain potentials X
and it's always gonna it's gonna toggle
along fundamental cuts so that the flow
obtained by Ohm's law gradually becomes
feasible
in more detail here's how dual codes
works so it's going to begin by still
Computing a low strep spanning tree
and it's going to initialize the initial
potentials to be zero and the
corresponding potential defined flow is
also zero
now in each iteration it's going to
sample a fundamental cut in the graph
and what it's going to do is going to
add a constant to the potential every
vertex in that cut where that constant
is exactly the amount that needs to be
added so that the resulting flow defined
by the potentials satisfies flow
conservation out of that cut
and so the running time of this
algorithm is going to be as follows
Computing the low set spanning tree
takes over to the end time just like
before
um the number of iterations is also all
sort of M time which is the stretch of T
just as before
however each iteration is going to take
over n time because it involves adding a
constant to the potential of every
vertex on one side of a fundamental cut
and that could take a little end time
because it could be all of n vertices in
that cut
here's an example of how it works so
let's look at the same example from V4
and recall the resistance Arts that are
equal to one
initially the potentials are initialized
to be zero
now in each iteration we're going to
sample a cut fundamental cut in the
graph so let's say we sample this one
here
the amount of flow that's supposed to be
flowing out of this cut is two but
currently zero flow is Flowing out
remember that the flow value of an edge
is given by the potential difference
divided by the resistance
since the resistance is R1 the flow is
just difference between the potential
and two endpoints so that all the flows
are zero right now
the algorithm is going to add a constant
to the potential of every vertex on one
side of the cut so that the resulting
potential induced flow has a flow value
of 2 coming out of the cut so the right
value to add in this case is two-thirds
because that's going to make each of the
edges coming out of the cut have a flow
value of two-thirds
and so the net flow value will be 2.
okay and the next iteration the
algorithm samples some other fundamental
cut let's say this one here
um there's currently a flow value of
two-thirds flowing out of this cut but
they're supposed to be minus one flow
flowing out of this cut
and so the algorithm is going to
subtract 5 9 from the potential of this
vertex here
so that the resulting flow out of this
cut is
-1
and the algorithm just repeats this
process and we can show that also in an
if you do this for nearly linear number
of iterations
then the resulting potentials are going
to converge to the solution of LX equals
B
now
just to give you an idea of how this can
be sped up using batching
so the naive runtime of this algorithm
is old till M end time because there's
all total M iterations and each
iteration takes o of n time
but note that
um
all the fundamental cuts that
um we need to be update they can
actually be sample in advance because
the probability distribution that
they're sampled from is fixed at the
very beginning it doesn't change over
time
and so we can generate all of these
updates in advance
and what we can do is we can split them
up into batches so let's call like the
batch this batch size equal to l
we can process out updates
simultaneously like at the same time
and what that allows us to do is if we
only focus on L updates we can contract
all of the tree edges that are not
involved in those L updates and so in
essence we're working with a contracted
tree of size L plus one in each batch
um that makes updates faster because
instead of adding having to add a
potential to full of end nodes we only
have to add the potential to of L nodes
because our tree only has size L plus
one now
um but there's also a downside because
after we finish processing the batch we
have to uncontract the tree and
propagate those trade changes back to
the full tree
and
um we can show that
um the best way to trade off these two
is by choosing the batch size to be
square root of N and that results in an
overall run time of O to the m to the
1.5
not in this talk are the following so we
didn't talk about the reduction to the
online Matrix Vector multiplication
which says that you know assuming this
this hardness conjecture if you
implement the iteration of the algorithm
one by one you can implement it if you
fastened or end time
and this is surprising because in the
COS algorithm you could Implement each
iteration with log n time even if you
just do them one by one
um so this shows that like in a dual
code setting where you do cut toggling
instead
these ideas like batching and you know
more complicated ideas are necessary to
improve the runtime
and I also didn't go into too many
details about the batching and also
um the more complicated algorithm using
sparsification recursion which allows
you to get the algorithm runtime Downs
old total to the M plus m to the power
of one plus little o of one
um so to summarize we're motivated by
The Crawling question which is
there is a cycle toggling algorithm
known for LX equals B the COS algorithm
but no cut toggling counterpart
but for Network flows there is usually
kind of a dual cut toggling algorithm to
any cycle toggling algorithm
so our research question was is there a
cut talking algorithm for solving
laplacian linear systems and if so how
fast can it run
and what we show is that there is a cut
targeting algorithm that's dual to the
COS algorithm and a naive implementation
takes all to the m iterations and or end
time per iteration
however unlike the COS algorithm where
you eat where each iteration can be
implemented logarithmic time
we show that assuming this online Matrix
Vector multiplication conjecture you
can't Implement each iteration of our
dual cos algorithm faster than o of n
time if you have to run them one after
the other
however by exploding the structure of
the updates we show that faster runtimes
of M to the 1.5 and M to the one plus
little or one time are possible using
batching and specification recursion